yeah and one of the things that's really
interesting as I kind of hear you
describe this is there's this weird
weird world where when Trump took office
kind of this America first type
mentality I don't think that it had
anything obviously to do with
coronavirus or kind of anything that's
transpired since he took office but in
some way we're almost backing into that
out of necessity so you see things like
let's bring all of our supply chains
back to the US a lot of this trade talk
right is the virus is almost forcing
that narrative now and and it's becoming
more accepted it seemed less as kind of
you know either racist or someway
discriminatory but one of the things
that you said in a recent presentation
things that the upfront summit is the
Americans strategic order that helped
them win the Cold War that's not the
strategic order that they're gonna need
to be successful in the future
right like that the important thing here
is there is a necessity of change
because the world is changing and the
countries that you describe kind of
recognize that what happens to the
countries that don't recognize this
right today yeah some of them won't be
countries much longer a little backstory
so the core idea that drives a lot of
what I do is why the United States did
what it did during the 20th century
so we're pulling into western Germany
during World War two and we're looking
on the horizon we see the Soviet war
machine to be perfectly blunt that's you
know that's kind of scary [ __ ] so we
were like okay this is in a different
hemisphere from us we cannot with sea
lift capacity fight the Soviets in
Europe we will lose that fight we need
everyone in Europe to be on our side so
we basically bribed them we rebuilt
their countries we provided them with
security overwatch we provided them with
the nuclear umbrella we opened our
market so they could export the way back
to being first world countries if in
exchange they allowed us to write their
security policies and that trade that
guns for butter trade is what enabled
the United States to ultimately prevail
in the Cold War the big problem however
is when we got to 1990 and the Cold War
was over
we voted out of office the president who
figured out what was next and then voted
in four successive presidents who didn't
care about Foreign Affairs much at all
and so we've just kind of been on drifts
now for thirty years and by providing
global security but not asking for
anything in return Americans became
steadily more disenchanted with the
world we know Trump is that not simply
the natural progression of that he's
just kind of the next step on the road
whoever comes after Trump is likely to
be less inclusive and less
internationalist than he is because the
economic structure will demand that
whoever is next go that direction so if
you look at say the the Democratic grip
yeah the Democratic primaries when we
had like a hundred and ninety five
thousand people trying to be President
all of them said that Trump was being
too soft on China and the trade talks
Trump is not nationalist by American
standards on trade he's kind of middle
in the road and the next phase of this
is gonna be far more mercantil than
anything that we've seen in the last 80
years yes oh speaking of China you've
pretty much said that they won't be a
unified or industrial country in the
next decade or so which I think kind of
shocks people but that's talk a little
bit just about why you believe that and
then what does the world look like if
you were right in that prediction sure
so China is one of the fastest aging
societies in the world
you hold a one-child policy for 35 years
you run out of 30 year-olds that's how
math works
the Chinese cannot interact economically
rent the rest of the world without a
global security paradigm in place they
don't have a long-range Navy in fact 90%
of their firepower can't sail more than
about a thousand miles from the shore so
that doesn't get into tort to any major
consumption clusters they import pretty
much all of the raw commodities that
allow them to function that's everything
from corn on one side to oil on the
other so if they don't control the sea
lanes which they can't they're
completely dependent upon American
security largesse just to exist and if
you look past back at the long stretch
of the history of the Han Chinese 3,500
years they very very rarely been unified
they're usually engaged in some sort of
civil war or fighting off some sort of
invasion neither of those goes well in
fact they're only period of peace and
prosperity and unity in their entire
history is under the american-led order
since 1946 specifically since 1990 and
if you look back to look simply achieve
political unity in the past most of that
period was under the Mongol occupation
this is not a place that holds together
well so they don't have the demography
they don't have the resources they don't
have the financial model they don't know
the physical access they don't know the
military capacity this only works when
someone from the outside forces everyone
to be on the same side that was the
american-led global order and that is
now over so the Chinese today with this
propaganda push on co vid it's not to
convince the world that the virus didn't
come from China
no one believes that it's to force a
nationalist uprising in China itself so
that people are willing to side with the
Chinese Communist Party in a period of
extreme political and economic stress
because that's what's coming for them
and if that doesn't work
China simply implodes yeah